hello i'm councillor robin drey and i'm  chairman of rocha district council  thank you to the local businesses who  provided free meals to children over  holiday  i couldn't be proud of our district i am  truly overwhelmed by the outpouring of  support  it comes during the difficult time for  the hospitalities industry  with many businesses struggling to cope  with the effects of corona restrictions  on their trade many local businesses  have helped their communities  and have provided food for vulnerable  children to stop them going hungry  they have also provided pre-made meals  that can be frozen or put in the fridge  to then heat up they have handed out  lunch boxes  communities have come together to donate  so thank you